The 30th movie in the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
a moving, fond farewell to a hero – but it's also
the start of something new. Warning: spoilers
ahead for "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever."
"You can come and find out."
"Black Panther: Wakanda Forever"
deals heavily with the fallout around the
untimely death of the nation's King T'Challa,
a development which mirrors the tragic, real-life
passing of actor Chadwick Boseman. In that way,
the film very much continues the tradition
of Marvel Phase 4 films dealing to some
extent with the themes of grief and loss.
However, while no one will forget T'Challa
or Boseman any time soon, the "Black Panther"
sequel also makes it clear there are other
heroes out there who can serve to usher in
the future of the MCU. Nowhere is this more
evident than in the introduction of new
character Riri Williams, aka Ironheart.
In "Wakanda Forever," Riri is a dedicated
and driven college student at MIT with a
penchant for creating ingenious high-tech
devices that get co-opted by the government,
like a vibranium detection device that
proves crucial to the movie's plot.
Fortunately, the authorities haven't yet gotten
their hands on her pièce de résistance — the
Ironheart armor.
"I am warningyou, do not take another step toward me."
"See how they teach the children to treat their guests."
After making a
big impression on the big screen, Riri
will return for her own Disney+ series,
appropriately titled "Ironheart." While there's
still much we don't know about the show, we can
glean a few things about where it's probably
going from the ending of "Wakanda Forever."
When we're first introduced to Riri Williams,
she's a 19-year-old college student, trying to
juggle a normal life with very abnormal interests.
It's safe to say the show will likely take place
in large part on this college campus, seeing
Riri juggle the task of building her Ironheart
armor with her attempts to be a regular student.
We also get a bit of her backstory in the movie,
as she reveals that her relationship with her
father fostered her interest in engineering.
Outside of Riri's story, Marvel has already
confirmed that a villain named The Hood will
function as an antagonist in the "Ironheart"
series. However, Riri will also likely go up
against another barrier along her solo journey.
In a key piece of dialogue featured in "Wakanda
Forever," Riri bemoans the fact that as a young
Black girl, she's rarely taken as seriously as she
should be, despite her remarkable intelligence.
It'd be a safe bet Riri will face similar problems
in "Ironheart," and have to overcome them as
a part of her growth as a person and a hero.
One thing that will have to happen in the
"Ironheart" series is this new heroine will
have to get herself a new suit of armor. There
are two Ironheart suits Riri Williams wears in
"Black Panther: Wakanda Forever." The first
is a rough prototype Riri's forced to deploy
when government officials close in on her
garage. However, for the film's final battle,
Riri gets one heck of an upgrade with an Ironheart
suit she makes courtesy of Wakandan technology.
While it's a pretty slick suit, it turns out
that Riri can't keep it. At the end of the movie,
Shuri tells Riri that while she's free to
return to MIT, the new Ironheart suit has
to remain in Wakanda. It makes sense; Wakanda
isn't exactly in a safe position on the world
stage by the movie's conclusion, so the Wakandans
probably don't want their revolutionary technology
to be seen on such a wide scale just yet.
As a result, one of the first things that's
probably going to take place in the "Ironheart"
show is Riri designing a new set of armor for
her to wear. The Hood is a formidable opponent
who uses magic, so Riri's going to need to use
all of her wits to come up with something that
can match him in combat. While all these details
paint a rough picture of what to expect with
"Ironheart," there's still plenty left that
will be a big surprise. We'll just have to
wait and see what the series has in store.